last question Ryan you
ready last
question top five favorite bands of all
time even a gun your head sorry about
that okay no no no no Chris Chris and I
not a gun to your head we play this game
all the time all right and now listen
you I know you have you're friends with
a lot of these guys but so you got to
really in Your Heart of Heart top five
bands okay top five bands I bet I can
get one of them okay PES mode tied
number one Smiths
no who who is tied with thees mode you
think the Smith no no uh the pesh
mode Durand Duran Beatles Beatles oh
yeah be all right and greatest song from
The Beatles for me she's leaving home
that is a three minute movie if you
listen to the lyrics of that write down
it's a movie it most incredible and the
way the chorus changes from she's
leaving home to she's having fun
fun just brilliant bre the pesh mode
Beatles beetles um it's got to be Mor or
Smiths I'm sure Tears for Fears oh I
love tears I just saw him at the ball
great yeah
uh Sergio menes
ah my all-time favorite song that Christ
is going to play at my wake in about 112
years time is
masanada it it's Brazilian I know it
yeah oh my gosh what a song it's just
and what's the last one the last one
is
maybe now Durand Duran dur having
spent seen them recently a number of
times in concert and realizing what an
incredible body of work they have and I
made a mistake a few years back when I
was uh actually having drinks with Simon
we were talking about uh you know radio
and touring and all different kinds of
things and I went God you're so lucky to
have so many songs and he looked at me
he goes has nothing to do with luck and
he he was right he was right it was it
was work you know I mean they put it
together um because so many bands would
kill to have that many songs it's uh
incredible